aujourd'hui celles qui travaillent par
nécessité ou par goût vous dirons
quelles sont d'après leur expérience les
difficultés d'avoir un métier ce métier
il faut d'abord le choisir et il est
bien certain que choisir a 14 ans quand
on finit à peine d'apprendre à lire et à
écrire ses joueurs à la loterie avec un
minimum de chances de gagner
monique et jeanine sa chair sont toutes
les deux dans ce cas elles appartiennent
à une famille de 14 ans ans elle
travaille dans une usine de matériel
téléphonique
elles se ressemblent et font tout pour
se ressembler peut-être parce que cela
tienne chaud quand on ne vit pas selon
son coeur vous avez le mettre en rage
les mérites man who is la même passion
oui il veut travailler
quel âge 18 ans est ce que c'est un
métier
mais en quel métier la culture g
l'intérieur des 12 pas parce que j'ai
travaillé un an et en bonne passe à 80
et est ce que vous aimez le métier j'ai
pas déplaisant c'est avec lino vous
préfériez la côte et en par oui ça se
comprend combien payez-vous par mois 53
54 milles par votre paye vous la donner
a retrouvé lizard et non je donne ma
paye mes parents régulièrement on
voulait vous avez votre sang j'ai ma
mère de mon argent combien avez-vous dix
mille francs par quinzaine sur lesquels
vous devez sortir et vous habituer que
vous pensez de votre fille elle vous
convient
[Musique]
bah oui on est bien obligé et quand il
faut rêver à votre vie avant la
voyez-vous quand dans la souhaitez-vous
plus aisés d'abord quand même s'ils
estiment qu'une jeune fille devrait
arriver à sortir avec moins de
difficultés sur un ton travail en avait
omis estime qu'on devrait y arriver
mieux que enfin et que vous apporte une
joie en dehors du fait que vous gagnez
de l'argent
ce que vous préféreriez restez chez vous
avec votre mère en parle oui ça c'est
automatique
vous préféreriez restez chez vous oui
comme vous aurez des avant centres aérés
clé et vous pensez avoir autant votre
maman en a une à non non vous ne voulez
qu a annoncé mi temps vous ne voudriez
pas dans la vie de votre mère non
j'admire mais il serait pas sa vie
pourquoi ce c'est trop difficile
et bien non travaillées n'est pas
toujours un plaisir
et pourtant qu'il arrive aussi qu'un
métier avec toutes ces fatick ses
déceptions vous donne quelques unes des
joueurs qu'on attendait de lui même s'il
est humble et difficile
pascal françoise anne marie sont amies
elles se retrouvent le lundi qui est
leur jour de congé
elles travaillent toutes les trois chez
un grand coiffeur parisien de nevers à 6
heures sans interruption
elles font des shampoings passe des
épingles toujours prévient obéir sans
oublier de sourire à des clientes riche
et ternel m'empresser elle vous
n'observez difficile de travailleuse par
le oui parce que c'est tout à fait
différent
ça me plaisait beaucoup mieux ce qui
avait pas de leçons à prendre mes
devoirs enfin on a beaucoup plus de
responsabilités on se prend déjà pour
une petite femme quoi quand on est
premier com avez-vous décidé de
travailler dans la coiffure soutenir que
j'avais à choisir entre les marchés et
puis il a coiffure mais je préférais me
thibaut coulas vous n'aimiez pas les
marchés non pas du tout pourquoi parce
qu'il fallait se lever tôt puis veille
avec
puis enfin du marché on était sale s'il
y avait plein de poussière alors combien
gagnez vous pardonne moi qu'elle s'en
faut par mois oui ogm égaux à peu près
en comptant les pourboires et puis par
semaine du pays par semaine trente mille
30 mille francs
vous gagnez rapide renvoyer ses 30000 km
an je donne toi maman est-ce que vous
guillaume vous étonne mes clientes oui
oui pourquoi ils croient elles sont
tellement différentes alors là alors
dites moi comment c'était différent
elles ont une vie stable
elles ont de l'argent alors alors vous
me l'avez pas vous en tout cas tu vas me
vais me laver difficilement oui tandis
que elle même si elle travaille même si
elles si elles gagnent beaucoup d'argent
par leur travail elles sont tellement
différente de nous elles ont une vie
tout à fait non pas de souci par exemple
ceci ménagers elles font leur travail
par exemple des directrices de couture
elles font leur travail et de rentrer
chez elle s'assied dans leurs bonnes qui
les servent tous assez elles sont pas du
tout pareil que nous menons un travail
mais c'est continuellement quand on
arrive à la maison n'a pas encore fini
travailler c'est pas pareil
ensuite dans une voiture elles peuvent
aller se promener s'il a envie de se
promener
même si elles ont des enfants laisse la
bonne garde les enfants tandis que nous
ont jamais espéré ça c'est vrai oui si
vous vous mariez base et continuer à
travailler
ah oui oui ce que vous rêvez quelquefois
l'épousé d'un homme très riche je suis
bien sûr comme toutes les jeunes filles
mais est-ce que vous en arrivez plus
particulièrement votre brouiller des
familles non parce que je trouve que des
trucs quand on a tout ce qu'il faut
quand on ne prend pas beaucoup à la vie
on est on appelle souvent on l'a tous
alors de quoi arriver vous je n'avais
pas de grand chose mais ce que j'aime me
suffit pour l'instant je m'estime très
très comblé même
à fontenay aux roses dans un cadre
agréable un foyer abrite 250 jeunes
filles pour lesquelles travailler c'est
en même temps faire l'apprentissage de
la liberté
roselyne et arlette exerce un métier
qu'elles ont choisie et qui leur
convient leur amour de l'indépendance
les fascine peut être un peu au
détriment de leur vie
vous êtes secrétaire g ii à quel âge
avez vous commencé le travail et flash
de 20 ans et saison saison vous avez
travaillé un temps hésité non par
nécessité par coup et est ce que vous
avez été déçu par notre a pas du tout
pas du lendemain norauto vous estimez
faire un travail agréables ou
désagréables à gré c'est-à-dire que vous
faites quoi
je m'occupe du courrier je prends tout
le courrier du directeur en sténo puis
je je classe des dossiers fait j'ai un
travail très intéressant alors le patron
l'expression c'est donner une définition
de m
tanner
c'est le type de l'homme désordonnée qui
se repose sur tout le monde
si on veut le patron c'est monsieur
charmant qui ne clique ne me contrarie
que très rarement
est ce qu'on pensait le mariage on ne
sait pas comment ça vous paraît il utile
non pas inutile mais pour l'instant j'en
vois pas du tout je ne vois pas mariés
pour l'instant dix ans ce n'est pas la
vocation
cela compte beaucoup dans votre ville
indépendante énormément et bien ne
prendre qu à compter sur soi puisque
tout ce sang peut pas faire autrement
sans indépendance pas de voyage plus de
solitude c'est embêtant
et c'était les vins secs monneret du
mariage bien évidemment quand je suis
parti je ne pense pas du tout à me
marier mais il faut bien quand même un
jour c'est une graine oui c'est plutôt
une femme venue de province elle aussi
andré a connu toutes les difficultés de
l'isolément du manque d'argent et du
manque de logements ses difficultés elle
les a vaincus patiemment et sans se
bercer d'illusions impossible et vous
rêviez d'être jetés nous disent qu'ils
n'ont pas tout à fait pareil et que
j'aurais bien aimé être insultes rice et
comme je n'ai pas pu aller au lycée il
ne restait que le travail non politburo
à choisir pourquoi ne pouviez vous pas
les glisser et bien il m'était difficile
d'aller au lycée étant donné que
c'était dans le 46 que j'aurais dû
rentrer à l'internât mais internat de
lycée dans la région que j'habitais à
l'époque étaient détruits par l'invasion
allemande donc pas possibilité pour mes
parents de de m'envoyer suivre les cours
du lycée j'ai choisi de venir à paris
pour différentes raisons d'abord les
salaires sont plus élevés et ensuite
parce qu'à paris on a davantage la
possibilité de se cultiver qu'en
province
et vous n'avez pas eu de difficultés en
arrivant à paris si j'évoque difficulté
ce logement une wave in toutefois les
cuisines étaient à peu près meublé avec
une cuisinière une table un buffet mais
la chambre n'était pas meublé
mais il a fallu que j'achète annie et
des fauteuils tout cela sur vos moi tout
cela sur mais moi oui
est ce que c'est votre rêve oh non c'est
loin d'être mon rêve parce qu'il n'y a
absolument pas d'air jamais jamais le
soleil il n'y a pas de fenêtre
il n'y a qu'une porte fenêtre qui va qui
pour entrer dans la pièce principale et
dans la cuisine il n'y a aucune ouverte
et combien gagnez-vous banques se
gagnent 50 mille francs
combien vous reste-t-il il me reste
trente mille francs pour vivre 38 francs
tranquille il fera nuit
c'est peu c'est très peu oui vous devez
vous priver
bien sûr il faut quelques privations
pour agréer
à vivre avec ce salaire combien drop par
an 2 2 combien de collier je vois que
vous en avez oui à peu près 2 également
pour aller avec la robe que j'achète et
le prix des robes vingt dix mille francs
c'est un maximum et vos sorties les
sorties et bien évidemment je choisis
des chevaux des sorties qui ne sont pas
trop chers et il y a quand même des
organisations des associations qui nous
permettent d'aborder billets à tarif
réduit vous avez très profondément le
souci de vous instruire et très
profondément
vous lisez les journaux j'ai lu les
journaux
oui et vous suivez la politique je la
suis d'assez près oui c'est à dire
surtout depuis le départ de mon frère en
algérie on ne peut pas on ne peut pas
concevoir eu une vie normale donc il y
aura un danger de lire qui posera même
dans quelques coins du globe que ce soir
on ne peut pas avoir
des centaines pour lesquelles le travail
selon ce qu'il est d'une obligation peut
devenir une voix elles sont des
centaines aussi qu'ils renonceraient
difficilement à l'indépendance et aux
espoirs qu'un métier le rapport il
faudrait seulement souhaité que ces
espoirs soit dans bien des cas plus
justement répartie et que grâce à une
bonne orientation professionnelle
travailler ne soit pas mené une vie ça
en joie
[Musique]